But much more interesting
than a Markov model for
what we're going to do is what's
referred to as a hidden Markov model.
So here's the basic idea.
Suppose you actually can't
observe the state, kay?
So there's some state doing its thing,
but you can't observe it.
But what you can observe, or
what are referred to as observables, or
the evidence.
So let's suppose for
the same weather example, okay?
Let's suppose the things that
we can observe are essentially
what women of the day happen
to be wearing or carrying.
So maybe I see this very sheik bathing
suit on a person, or I see just a nice
coat that can be worn any time
that it was sunny, or an umbrella.
So these are the evidence
of what the state is.
So before I can go further,
I have to tell you one more thing
about our Markovian system, and
that's what's referred to as
the emission probabilities.
Emission, if you think of it
as symbols being spit out, and
the emission probabilities
are written like this.
B, sub j of k.
And what that means is,
the probability that you'll see symbol
k, that you'll see a bathing suit,
given that at some time you're
in some particular state, okay?
So what's the probability you'll see
a bathing suit, given that it's sunny?
What's the probability
you'd see a bathing suit,
given that it's snowy, all right?
Those are called
the emission probabilities.
And what that means, our entire system
when it's running, looks like this.
In this new system,
where we can't observe the states, we
don't ask questions about the likelihood
of having seen a particular sequence of
states, because we can't see the states.
Instead, we're going to ask
about the likelihood, or
the probability of seeing a particular
sequence of observations.
So that's shown here.
So you could say, given this
sequence of observation, coat,
coat, umbrella, umbrella,
bathing suit, umbrella,
umbrella, what's the probability of that
series of that sequence of observations?
Well, we could evaluate that if
you give us everything, right?
So here, I've just written it out
as P of O is the sequence of all
the observations, and I know the way to,
to compute that and we'll get more
of the details later is, I can say well,
if you told me the sequence of states,
then I can tell you the probability
of given observation.
And if I multiply that by
the probability of that sequence,
I can get the whole thing.
So one simple example is, well,
one possible sequence of states,
just one, is that it's all sun.
All right, and that can be determined
from the yellow stuff here, all right?
All right, so it's the probability that
I start with sun, 0.7, right there.
And then I follow that with a whole
bunch of sun, 0.8, point, right?
All e, sunny days.
So, this is the probability of
all sunny days, and this would
be the probability of seeing this
sequence, if every day was sunny, right?
So, the coat,
it's a 0.3 probability t, there's 4,
umbrellas, and there's only a 10% chance
of seeing an umbrella when it's sunny.
Notice by the way,
I wrote 0.1 to the 4 here.
The order doesn't matter, right?
because I'm assuming that
if you tell me the state,
that I could tell you the probability
of being, of, of having an umbrella.
It doesn't matter what the day before or
the day after was.
You tell me that it's,
that it's raining,
I can tell you the probability
that they're carrying an umbrella.
But this was only for
one particular sequence of all sun.
You have to worry about all
possible sequences of weather,
over those seven days to talk about the
probability of getting this one series.
So to make that a little clearer and
a little easier, let's just do the math.